this is what GQ is considering the
pullout of the summer it so bad there's
so many brands playing in this game
right now hmm top man all the way up to
Dolce Tom for GQ we're considering the
go-to polos the ban on polar this summer
go away what is a vamp although usually
pull those are just cut across it just
sewn at the bottom hemmed at the bottom
the ban line there's always gonna be an
elastic band around the waist and also
in the sleeve it's breathable it's great
for summer when it's hot out it looks
like a lot of these have great like
patterns or stripes stripes on the
collars there's gonna be retro prints
small pattern large pattern mixes with
solids it's a great shirt and tie
alternative to wearing under a suit it
looks fantastic you look super sharp
it's casual chic exactly so John why
don't you just kind of show me some of
these ones that you picked out let's
take a look at one of the patterns that
we like a lot is the chest stripe it can
be worn with pretty much anything and
any guy can pull this off this next one
has a very retro vibe it's an all-over
large-scale pattern can we pull up great
with the trouser we like this one it has
that cool 1970s tennis v that has the
stripes on the collar as well in the
waistband it gives that extra added
sporty element this one's by Orly and
what we liked about this one it doesn't
have any buttons on the collar
I love that print what's great about
this print is that it's tonal it can be
worn kind of any way with anything any
guy can pull this off are you guys
that's a wrap you heard it from us the
band la polo is the pull of the summer
get out there and find one that works
for you
you